folks Chris waters here on the Samsung
stage at gamespot's live show for me 3
2014 I just had the hop over from over
there and joining me now on the couch is
cloud use from flying wild hog uh that's
the name of the studio not how you got
here right oh yeah oh that's it I'm up
against you alright cloud you sure here
to show off juju let actually show up
that shirt cuz we got we got some few
characters and juju here is it like a
team go and pay Oh juju and pay oh hey
oh the other character he's a sidekick
OC got quite a cheeky little duo there I
like them yeah thanks alright so I like
you're getting a hint of the aesthetic
of the game here we've got some some
gameplay to show off but let's talk
about due to what kind of game is this
yeah so juju is a classical
side-scrolling 2d platformer mm-hmm with
boss fights and secret levels and the
many more things but the main feature
that we think is the main feature for us
is the co-operative mode which is not a
regular cooperative mode but the a
symmetric one okay so you got so juju
and pay oh don't just run wrong screen
side by side yeah yeah so a symmetric
means that players with different skills
can play at the same time and both have
fun oh the park they are playing at the
same time but they've got different
stuff yeah one character is requires
different skills than the other so you
can play with someone who's who doesn't
need much challenge which one is a
better player one with a beginner player
okay so one of the one of the characters
has a little bit more of a skill base to
timing based skill set so we're seeing
this is just a one player it's a single
player part of the game I mean you you
can play all the levels in single player
or multiplayer in fact the second player
can opt in or opt out at any time in
middle of the level or in the middle of
a boss fight or anything or they get a
better offer they can just run out of
the living room and go do something else
yeah yeah because sometimes someone gets
a phone call or something like that and
the other player
continue gameplay without waiting for
him it's especially important with kids
because kids sometimes want to play with
you and sometimes they just stare and
don't wants to go forward so you can
continue playing and when they get
interested again they can grab a
controller and continue with you so
definitely a very family friendly sort
of thing yeah yes I now we see the
multiplayer happening in fao tagging
along sort of doing a little float
action with the belly bloat is I'm
saying yeah so there are multiple speeds
that you learn as you play through the
game also one of the skill is floating
in the air and the player has is being
inflated when she can float in the air
and slowly drop so and then there's a
roll yeah there's a roll we call it dash
so with us you can dash for example camo
over obstacles on or defeat enemies it's
the sort of attack what are all these
things that they are grabbing here these
are Amber's at the beginning of the game
it explained that the main enemy the
main hope that you are repeating he is
changed by a set of numbers and when he
escapes into that water corrupted of
this work she froze those numbers around
the world you have to gather all of them
to access enemies bosses and final boss
and defeat him and get rid of him all
right I so you're grabbing those but
then you're also occasionally hitting
these little nuts and busting an open
and like doing some dance moves yeah I
still there right yeah yeah yeah so
there are a few skills that you learned
because the story is that your father
jumpy was kidnapped and you a young
shaman Panther get the mask a shaman
mask from him okay and you learn a few
skills by using this mask one of skill
is dashing one of skill is chanting and
dancing and by chanting and dancing you
can activate some items or stun enemies
by making them dance for your chanting
so it's a way of stunning enemies and
making them easier to ya
you know an enemy can't be attacking you
if they're dancing yeah it's a bit of a
hardcore in this game is that that you
make them dance and then you can kill
them then and took a dark turn their
cloud you yeah I don't know well there
and they're bad guys at least they they
died in a joyful fashion yeah yeah you
know not like dying you just freeing
them from jerseyville free from the
spell of the evil guy i but dancing is
not it is sort of very in sync with the
playful tone of juju yeah you guys are
really leaning into that that a colorful
fun kind of aesthetic yeah it's actly
there's some music vibe to it the items
that can be activated by dancing car
throwing those notes so you can see what
what you can activate with that at any
point you encourage the the players to
take a little break put this patrol down
and dance that's my dance miserable
they're not good about it yeah alright
so now we're on to this sort of beach
world and everything is kind of like
inflated like being over inflated
balloons and flag at item so it's an
underwater world so you part of it you
play on the surface but part of it you
can dive into water and swim but the
unique thing is that we have inflated
environment here very important why
she's an enemy sir Vegas yeah can you
dance underwater yes you can all right
you can even play music underwater come
on and yeah I mean you know music
underwater yet that's how whales top
right yeah I see it like clearly you
guys had a lot of fun just designing
these the silly like colorful worlds
yeah I definitely kind of harkens back
like like another game I was demoing on
stage over there Pillai hunter origins
are kids back to it this sort of debt
heyday of fun goofy mascot platformers
in color more pressing sir well it's a
classical platformer game so well we we
did different kinds of games before but
at some age you you just come back
to the roots when when you played
classical platformers like mario games
and Donkey Kong game since what you want
to do something like that the other
thing is that for example I have a
six-year-old child with whom I would
like to play games yeah and maybe not
Call of Duty or battlefield games but or
shadow warrior yeah the world for
example but something that like a plan
with him and have fun with him and she's
not that he would have fun with me so I
couldn't find really anything that that
would be played that way so that's when
the idea came to do something that I'm
something like this yeah and so how does
he like it he loves it yeah we do a lot
of focus testing on kids yeah bulky it's
like from six to ten years old haha and
for what good so what kind of feedback
do you get from you know giving a gig
like a kid that agent begin the game I
mean you can watch them play and see you
know I could count their smiles per
minute or how many times how where
they're getting for that we can show
them a panda bear because the main hero
is a panda bear panda bear but we shall
show them white panda bear and this pink
one and I said no though I found a bar
seems that she's being funny so there
they have strange ideas about the game
but they're very insightful it's still
you know a pink panda bear it seems i
drew people yeah maybe more games should
do that you know yet get started a kid
focus testing a slab you know so kids
don't look at like technical graphical
features like specular bump mapping
traders and sat on the kids aren't
asking you if it runs in 60 frames per
second it's a pity yeah yeah they don't
they see if graphics is vivid and
colorful they like it they like it and
vivid and colorful you guys have nails
here choo-choo uh what so what platform
is this being played on right now so
right now it's on pc and playstation
free in digital so PSN and steam we are
also working on xbl I version for xbox
36
but I can confirm ps3 and sistemas team
this fall very cool my big xbla baby
xbla see how it goes yeah uh so what
happened I noticed you know we've got
the heart meters on here what happens
when they fall on to some cartoony
inflated spikes out what the data sort
of pop back in or do you have to sort of
go back so in multiplayer it works that
way that if one character gets a bubble
becomes a bubble the other character can
play on and the first character can
respawn at his point so the only way to
die in multiplayer mode is that involve
directions die at the same time I'll get
bubbles yeah you Bob get the bubble gang
gets back to checkpoint and have to
restart but it's it's pretty hard to do
it yeah now two players of course you
just want looks to enjoy the game it's
not necessarily about that that
challenge that a lot of other games sort
of go for it yeah there are also more
hardcore modes in this game oh yeah yeah
because we wanted to do a game that is
its challenge is adapting to the player
so everybody has can find something for
him so if you want if you come to it and
you want that tougher challenge yeah you
can find it yeah so for example if you
all the levels have secrets in them and
then just secrets there are mini levels
which challenges times challenges like
you have 30 seconds to gather all under
siege from from a room and if you
complete all of them you unlock a
hardcore level 4 for certain work and
after beating difference cart or level
which is pretty challenging you unlock a
hardcore mode for for this whole game
okay so then you can play but you have
only one heart since you can get the
additional cards so one kids means that
your attempt you have the other way to
Wallace yeah now we're seeing one of the
boss battles you mentioned way out here
with this giant octopus which I like yes
I like the plug on the inflatable
octopuses head that's a really nice
reminds me the beach toys I used to play
with back in the day exactly I so but
this is sort of you know those big scale
multi-stage you get to the air boss and
Lego uh yeah there's a whirlpool all of
a sudden yeah so I could as you can see
there are multiple stages of boss fights
so you can learn it patterns and repeat
each stage and learn what happens in the
next stage and also the interesting
things about the boss fight we have nine
ball part of boss fights all together
okay but you meet each of us twice each
of first four boss fights twice the
first time you meet him after you defeat
him he doesn't die because these pegs
and give you a special skill like pawns
and elastic escape yeah like a skill of
floating in mid-air okay like like you
saw inside that lizard that was the
large skill and in the second encounter
of that the boss fight you need to use
that specific skill to defeat him so
like for example in this boss fight you
learned skill of swimming underwater
open diving before in the side in the
first encounter off of octopus you play
the octopus and now you have to use this
swimming underwater to defeat him and so
you know your building skills Brad get a
couple new tricks throughout the game
yeah for each box you get additional
skill that you can you throughout the
game you can backtrack to previous
levels and use that skill so to fight
any measure to make better score for
example all right I really know the more
the more we see the more you tell me
about it it really is just give like
taking me back to these days of like
renting a sega game on the weekend it's
a game like this playing with my little
brother or you know selfishly denying
him the opportunity to play as all
brought older brothers sometimes do hi
but
put the smile on your face yeah we hope
so alright it looks like this boss
battle is getting getting real heated
who's this other this guy like banging
on the belly bongos this is a totem that
you can activate with music throughout
the game he opens some passages but fear
key is used to to vanquish the boss to
vanquish the boss exactly and now of
course we have to have a dance party
yeah this is a stuff that you get from
the second encounter of the bus if you
complete that stuff you can unlock the
passage to the final four at the end of
the game and defeat him and rescue your
father very cool well Claudia juju
looking delightful looking like a really
fun sort of thank you very much
father-son game or you know brother
sister game sometimes although gamers
let's keep old and younger so it can be
played vice versa yeah absolutely you
never know absolutely a good point you
know parents whose kids clamor for video
games but maybe don't haven't grown up
playing yes I can you touch with their
parents to to play games there you go
yeah alright and so you said playstation
3 and steam confirmed working on xbla
but i wasn't your targeted release date
for juju have fall 2014 so it's soon
very soon claudius thank you so much for
coming very much just showing it off
here on the stage at e3 2014 we are
going to be back with some goblin
platforming stealth action and sticks
but before we go do that we're going to
head up to the game spot newsroom do a
check in on the latest news here at e3